Parts of Southern California
reeling from intense rainfall
caused by Tropical Storm Hillary.
Palm Springs alone
saw nearly a full year's worth of rain
in just 24 hours.
CNN's Stephanie
Elam is in the Cathedral City for us
in California, right near Palm Springs.
What are you seeing, Stephanie?
Still seeing a lot of mud
out here in the earthmovers or out
trying to clean it up here.
What else I can tell you?
We just learned
that Interstate Ten is open.
However, there's a catch.
You have to get off the freeway
and get back on it.
Whether you're going east or west.
And that's what that line of semi-trucks
is up there waiting for.
But all in all, across
Southern California,
there is a lot to clean up after Hillary
Southern California
facing unprecedented flooding
holy violent mudslides,
flash floods,
damaging roads and homes
after bearing
the brunt of Tropical Storm Hillary.
There's a lot of destruction
in rivers of flash flood water
taking over the streets
of Cathedral City overnight
and neighborhoods in nearby Palm Springs.
Into the early morning,
piles of thick
mud left behind from floodwaters
blanketing everything in sight.
The mud inescapable
for anyone attempting to get around.
We're absolutely telling people
if they don't have to be out
to stay in their homes.
One, the roads,
we're still assessing the damage
and the places where there's still water
and mud over the roads.
We don't know how safe those are.
Jay Bubbler
spent the night into the morning
rescuing drivers
stuck on flooded and muddy roads.
What kind of conditions
were you seeing while you were out there?
Cars floating
and there was cars
that were almost washed out.
He echoed authorities warnings
to stay off the roads.
A lot of them are regretting
that they tried to get across to it
to save it.
Over here,
they have dad's car
and Dad doesn't know it yet.
So I'm guessing around it.
When you see water, you don't cross it.
The area around
Palm Springs
saw nearly a year's worth of rain
in just 24 hours.
I spent the night on the roof
of my truck,
disabling 911 emergency calls overnight.
Downtown Los Angeles
experienced the rainiest
summer day on record, going back
more than 100 years.
Los Angeles was tested,
but we came through it.
The Los Angeles
Fire Department
fielded more than 4000
emergency calls on Sunday.
And responded to about 800 incidents.
Los Angeles
Public Schools were closed on Monday,
while officials surveyed
facilities for damage.
Take all those conditions into account.
After careful consideration,
we decided to shut down the schools.
Right decision.
The Los Angeles Angels to play
the Cincinnati Reds on Wednesday,
postponing their home game
because of the effects from the storm
so much rain in San Diego.
A tower of water was seen erupting
from a manhole today.
The city saw its rainiest
summer day in over 170 years.
Getting ten times
their average summer rainfall
in just one day.
The cleanup effort
the top priority
after the rain
with Hillary
continuing to move through the west.
Millions will still remain under flood
watches from California to Idaho.
And back out here in Cathedral City.
Wolf, you just got to see how thick
this mud is.
Even after the water
has been receding through the day.
I can still sink down into it.
Here, and that is what's encased.
These couple of cars here behind me.
And I know that they got there now
by floating in the thick of the storm.
That shows you
how fast the water was moving.
Out there.
In the distance,
you may hear more equipment
and that's
because they're digging out homes
in some of these
residential neighborhoods Wolf.
Yeah, a terrible, terrible situation.
Stephanie Elam,
thank you for that report.